Nancy Pelosi in the illustrious AOC get
into a catfight can we even say that a
Democratic Senate hopeful implodes on
launch and Trump's labor secretary
battles allegations of a sweetheart deal
with pedophile Jeffrey Epstein I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
I said should say alleged pedophile
Jeffrey Epstein I believe he has pled
guilty to prostitution solicitation in
Florida it's still alleged that he's a
pedophile elderly the evidence is pretty
solid
at this point we'll get to all of this
in just one second first a rise in
geopolitical tensions have actually led
to a five-year high in global prices so
if you'd bought you know like six months
ago you'd be real happy person right now
Iran announced it will break the uranium
stockpile limit but they agreed to under
the nuclear deal it is not a coincidence
that gold prices have been rising
steadily since the tanker bombings in
Iran continues to create chaos in the
Middle East none of this is a surprise
because as I've been telling you for the
past four years gold is a safe haven
against uncertainty is it part of your
plan it should be hedge against
inflation and hedge against uncertainty
an instability with precious metals my
savings plan is diversified in yours
should be as well the company I trust
with precious metal purchases Birch gold
group I know the folks at Birch gold
group they're terrific look back
historically when the bottom falls out
of everything else
Gold tends to safeguard savings Birch
gold group has thousands of satisfied
customers countless five-star reviews an
A+ rating with the Better Business
Bureau terrific customer service by the
way contact Birch gold group get a free
information kit on physical precious
metals right now see if diversifying
into gold and silver at least a little
bit makes sense for you they have a
comprehensive 16 page kit revealing how
gold and silver can protect your savings
they can legally move that IRA or 401k
out of stocks and bonds into a precious
metal say our IRA if that's something
that you're into to get that no-cost
no-obligation kit Tech's been to 47 47
47 again text my name Ben - 47 47 47
look to diversify at least a little bit
into precious metals in a chaotic era
okay so we begin today with the mother
of all cat fights I know we're not
supposed to say Catholic we were
informed by aoc that if two women have a
fight over nearly nothing that you are
supposed to not call this a cat fight
because it is sexist in some way sure
even though the term cat fighting has
been used to apply to men even though
the term cat fighting has been part of
what's to come for a very long time now
it is called cat fighting if two women
have an incredibly petty and public feud
which is exactly what AOC and Nancy
Pelosi are having right now because they
don't actually disagree all that much on
policy Nancy Pelosi just sort of hides
the ball a little bit more the
difference between Nancy Pelosi and AOC
is that Nancy Pelosi is a smart person
and AOC is not a smart person
Nancy Pelosi does not have the right
principles but which is a
battle-hardened veteran of the
congressional Wars she knows how to
publicly face the policies that she is
putting forward
she's much cleverer than ALC which is
why she's the Speaker of the House and
AOC is the representative of one of the
bluest districts in America after
winning a primary against another
Democrat they said it's a notion that a
OC is any sort of real leadership
challenger for Nancy Pelosi at least in
terms of skill set is a complete fiction
and it's a fiction promoted by the media
and what's amazing and ironic and
delicious about all of this is that
Nancy Pelosi made this happen
so ALC started to get media attention
and Nancy Pelosi basically had two
choices ignore it just pretend that a is
he was another member of the crowd and
she could have done that and she could
have just done that and then the other
thing she could have done it she could
have promoted ALC she could have said I
love the new energy that AOC is bringing
to our party I love the fact that AOC
really is channeling the future of the
Democratic Party and she chose sort of
both and that's the worst strategy
because on the one hand she was patting
aoc on the head telling AOC that AOC is
brilliant and wise and wonderful and
energetic and on the other hand she was
saying quite publicly that she thinks
AOC is basically an idiot that her
policies make no sense and that she has
no constituency well that's not gonna
make a OC particularly happy so this is
actually Nancy Pelosi's fault because
what you should have been doing was
downplaying these jokers from the start
she should have been downplaying AOC she
should have been downplaying rashida
talib she should have been downplaying L
hen Omar should have always said that
they were a very small contingent of the
democratic party and she shouldn't have
been patting them on the head for their
energy because you know what else has
energy a rabid dog lots of things have
energy lots of bad things have energy
and Nancy Pelosi was trying to channel
that energy Nancy Pelosi wanted the best
of both worlds she wanted to be able to
utilize the cocaine like power of
identity politics that is now bubbling
up from the base of the Democratic Party
she wanted to harness it and then she
wanted to use it in her own particular
way but she didn't want any of the
after-effects of all of that well that's
not how this works the Republican Party
by the way has found out the same thing
in the 2016 primaries every single
candidate tried to do this with Donald
Trump every single candidate tried to
use Donald Trump they tried to say okay
well Donald Trump you know made this
with Donald Trump and his but his folks
are really energetic and he's bringing a
new interesting energy to the death to
the Republican Party primaries and they
figured okay eventually he would fade
and they pick up his support and then
they would just move on with that sort
of cocaine energy power that Trump was
bringing to the table in 2016 well by
the time they realized that Trump's base
was sticking with him by the time they
realized that Trump was legitimate
player it was too late for them to do
anything now where Pelosi has an
advantage is that AOC does not have a
national crowd Mayo's for all of the
talk about AOC being this tremendously
powerful political player she is not but
she certainly perceives herself that way
and she's utterly unhinged she's utterly
unhinged when it comes to her practice
of politics so she is not holding back
anymore so we sort of have to reverse
and explain what Nancy Pelosi was doing
here so again Nancy Pelosi spent her
early days posing with AOC on the cover
of Rolling Stone magazine talking to how
these new freshmen women they were just
bringing this new wonderful zeitgeist
and energy to Congress and they have
such great new ideas and then she'd go
out publicly and she would say stuff
like this well we won this election it
wasn't in districts like mine or
Alexandria's however wonder and she's a
wonderful member of Congress I think all
of our colleagues will attest but those
are districts that are solidly
Democratic this glass of water would win
with a D next to them in those districts
and not to not to diminish the the
exuberance and the personality and the
rest of Alexandria and the other members
exuberance and personality we want the
exuberance we want the personality but
let's be real about this the only reason
she's in Congress is because she was in
the bluest district on planet earth and
she made these kind of comments Pelosi
did over and over and over again over
the past six months she called the green
New Deal the green dream or whatever
sure nough mocked it suggested the green
dream or whatever they call it nobody
knows what it is but they're for it
right she referred to the green new deal
which was a o C's chief policy priority
involving the murder of millions of
farting cows in the grounding of all
airplanes as quote one of several or
maybe many suggestions that we receive
and she's sort of shuffled it off to the
side because it received zero votes in
the Senate and then
she was asked about aoc swing and she
got kind of upset about it and she said
listen ALC swing is like five people she
likes to minimize the conflicts within
her caucus between the moderates and the
progressives you have these wings AOC
and her group on one side it's like five
people know the progressive group it's
more than aggressive I'm a progressive
okay so there was Nancy Pelosi again
dismissing AOC and then just a few days
ago she did an interview with the New
York Times with Maureen day out over the
New York Times and she said all these
people have their public whatever and
their Twitter world but they don't have
any following therefore people that's
how many votes they got a hundred
percent accurate I've been saying it
since the very beginning the difference
is I think that AOC is a blight on our
politics I think the Nancy Pelosi is
similarly a blight on our politics when
a clever blight on our politics at the
very least the problem is once you
attack aoc you can't put that genie back
in the bottle
hey the AOC is a result of identity
politics
she's a result of unhinged progressivism
and that may fuel energy but like
cocaine there is a very strong temporary
high and then the long-term effects
start to kick in the John Belushi effect
on politics is very much in evidence
here a lot of brilliance and crazy and
wacky and then comes the downside it's
really it's bad for Nancy Pelosi because
now a OC is upset and AOC has basically
suggested that the Nancy Pelosi is a
racist so the fight is now out in the
open
both of these sides are going at each
other hammer and tongs and I'm here for
it man hook it straight into my veins
this is my political cocaine so Nancy
Pelosi said on Wednesday she had quote
no regrets about a comment published
over the weekend that seemed to dismiss
the influence of some of her highest
profile freshmen including AOC and
privately urged those Democrats to train
their fire on Republicans not on their
own colleagues Pelosi said I have no
regrets about anything in fact she got a
neck tattoo that said no regrets Pelosi
suggested to Maureen's out of course
that the so-called squad had limited
following inside the house I saw
somebody online referred to a OSI and
her followers as Sandinistas which I
kind of loved Pelosi said all these
people have their public whatever their
Twitter world they didn't have any
following therefore people that's how
many votes they got
Pelosi defended those comments after
leaving a closed-door caucus meeting
according to the Washington Post where
she delivered a stern warning to her
party's left to keep their criticism of
fellow Democrats to themselves she noted
it was the party's more moderate members
who delivered control of the house to
Democrats accurate and asked lawmakers
to be respectful of that she said a
majority is a fragile thing she said
that people like AOC should show some
level of respect and sensitivity to more
moderate colleagues she said you make me
the target but don't make our moderates
the target in all of this because we
have important fish to fry well that's
not stopping a OC because she is not
going to be quieted by this elder
stateswoman is basically lucille bluth
here trying to hold back the passions of
Buster it's pretty it's pretty fantastic
in other recent tweets the the
legislative mastermind sang a psychic
Chakrabarti who may or may not be
involved in some campaign finance issues
with AOC that is a o C's chief of staff
criticized Pelosi and moderate Democrats
via Twitter he said all these articles
want to claim what a legislative
mastermind Pelosi is but I'm seeing way
more strategic smarts from the four
freshmen members Pelosi has just man she
got outmaneuvered by the Republicans but
that's not really where the the baseline
of this is we have the baseline of this
is that AOC is now calling Pelosi a
racist and that is just phenomenal
because Pelosi deserves the new rule as
my business partner Jeremy boring now
verified on Twitter points out he points
out that racism is basically the
all-purpose term for I disagree with
somebody to my left so Donald Trump is a
racist because he disagrees with Nancy
Pelosi and now Nancy Pelosi is a racist
because she disagrees with aoc but a OSI
told the New York or radio our quote I
said I think sometimes people think we
have a relationship not particularly ooh
cutting I love this stuff this is so
good and then she suggested the
Washington Post that Pelosi was a racist
quote when these comments first started
I kind of thought she was keeping the
progressive flank at more of an arm's
distance in order to protect more
moderate members which I understood but
the persistent singling out it got to
the point where it was just outright
disrespectful the explicit singling out
of a newly elected women of color
boom drop the mic she played
the woman of color card Nancy Pelosi
down start that count oh boy
so now AOC is suggesting that Nancy
Pelosi doesn't like AOC because AOC is
brown that's the actual suggestion that
Nancy Pelosi who's openly explaining why
she's got a problem with AOC and she
keeps selling AOC and these freshman
members stop talking about primary our
members stop tweeting about fellow
Democrats it's a it's obnoxious it's bad
for us it undercuts our legislative
agenda Nails is like you're just saying
that cuz you hate me because you're a
racist man Nancy Pelosi the Democrats
deserve every every every aspect of this
every single grain of that identity
politics cocaine they've been snorting
for years it's now coming back in the
form of serious mental problems and it
is it is delicious and it is well
deserved never get high off your own
supply says cocaine Mitch and that is
exactly what happened here the Democrats
got high off their own supply the
identity politics was a weapon it was
supposed to be used against people on
the right and now because it has infused
every vein in the Democratic body
politic it's gonna be used against
anyone you disagree with including a
Nancy Pelosi who's sitting there going
what the hell I shared it Obamacare and
ran Congress for this for this pipsqueak
to come and call me a racist because I
think that she's incompetent yes I'll
give you more of it in just one second
because it's fantastic but first it is
coming the biggest shopping day on the
planet I'm talking about Amazon Prime
they know as you know I am an Amazon
person I am there for Amazon all day
every day it is the greatest service in
the history of mankind and Amazon Prime
day is fantastic it's the most insane
day of savings across the Internet's
largest marketplace but did you know
there's such a thing as prime day pretty
much every day it is indeed possible and
it's easy all you have to do is use
honey honey is a free browser extension
that searches the internet for coupon
codes then like magic it automatically
applies them to your cart at checkout
you know that honey also works on Amazon
even though Amazon doesn't have discount
codes whenever you shop on Amazon honey
searches every last one of Amazon's two
million plus sellers to make sure that
you are getting the lowest price
possible I've saved bunches of money on
Amazon just using honey it really is
fantastic honey even factors in sales
tax shipping amazon prime status you're
not gonna get fooled
shipping price or any of that sort of
stuff simply put if there's a better
price honey we'll find it in seconds
I've been using honey for months at this
point maybe years at this point and it
is it's got to have saved me at least
hundreds maybe thousands of dollars add
honey for free in just two clicks it is
that easy start saving today on prime
day and every day for that matter add
honey for free at join honey calm slash
Ben that is joined honey calm / man
honey online savings simplified join
honey calm / Ben and get it installed
for free alrighty so aoc going after
Pelosi calling her a racist yes yes so
the way that this has been working for
Democrats for years now is that if you
disagree with Democrats you are a racist
Nancy Pelosi no disagree disagrees with
a OSI and that means that she is a
racist which I'm sure is I'm sure that's
where this is going hilarious hilarious
she posed on the cover of Rolling Stone
with AOC and with Rasheeda Talib and
with ohon Omar and now that three-person
caucus is turning on Nancy Pelosi and
now categorizing her with whom Tucker
Carlson that's that's the other person
that Ilhan Omar is going after today
Allah Nomar suggesting the Tucker
Carlson is a racist because he said our
immigration system is broken if it's
bringing in people like Ilhan Omar who
have such a negative view of the country
so I guess Nancy Pelosi is now part of
the Tucker Carlson crew amazing how as
the Overton Window shifts laughs Nancy
Pelosi is going to end up being like the
co-host of this show by the time the
left is done it's insane it's totally
crazy and Nancy planned an ALC isn't
done whining either and she's feeling
very sad for herself despite the fact
that she's insanely prominent based on
having won a primary in the bluest
district in America she's insanely
prominent based on the fact that she's
passed zero legislation or even really
been involved in series Eero serious
pieces of legislative movement and she's
incredibly famous and well-known because
she is very good at the Twitter clap
Beck's or at least her ghost writers are
AOC is and she's feeling very whiny
about herself so how lining is she she's
complaining now that the Democrats are
keeping her too busy she says they're
trying to just give me busy work so that
I don't make trouble
they're just she's like a third grader
who's upset that the teacher has put her
in the corner and given her the the Bart
Simpson project of writing over and over
on a piece of paper I will not
besides other moderate Democrats so
here's a Aussie complaining that she's
so busy they're keeping me busy so that
I can't do the important stuff you know
like talk about farting cows and all I
think that ultimately I'm fine with the
decision especially given the committee
assignments that I was ultimately given
which were very intense and very
rigorous I was assigned to two of some
of the busiest committees and four
subcommittees so my hands are full and
sometimes I wonder if they're trying to
keep me busy yeah that's it that's it
they're trying to keep you busy because
you are so impactful and so important
you know this is what happens Nancy when
you give small children unearned
self-esteem and this is this is what
happens and and by relative terms
AOC is the child in the Congress I mean
she's the youngest person in the
Congress she doesn't know anything and
Nancy Pelosi gave her all sorts of
credibility she gave her all sorts of
power and now she's feeling the brunt of
that
when she tells aoc to stop mouthing off
on Twitter quite so much it's pretty
it's pretty phenomenal it AO c is the
teenager Nancy Pelosi is the mom and
Nancy Pelosi keeps screaming for a OC to
turn down the music and AOC is turning
up the music and doing whatever she
wants in that bedroom of hers and not
only that she's then coming downstairs
and calling mom the b-word
and it is fantastic now this does have
some broader ramifications because AOC
does actually represent the loudest wing
of the party even though that wing of
the party is minority of the party so
AOC is not merely restricting her
criticism to other congressional
candidates she's also going after Joe
Biden so she said in the last couple of
days she was slamming Joe Biden
suggesting that the debate raised
questions about his capacity Joe Biden
his performance on the stage kind of
raised some questions with respect to
that but I don't want to say just
because someone is 79 they can't or
shouldn't run for president I don't want
to use those proxies that a number as a
proxy for capacity I think you have to
assess a person's capacity kind of on a
case-by-case basis
yay well now AOC by the way not only is
ripping Biden she's back like it
last few minutes - ripping Pelosi so she
was just asked by Manu Raju who's a
reporter over at CNN if she stands by
her comment that Pelosi singles out
women of color quote well I think it's
really just pointing out a pattern right
we're not talking about progressives
it's singling out for individuals and
knowing the media environment were
operating in knowing the amounts of
death threats we get knowing the amounts
of concentration of attention I think
it's worth asking why yes yes and yes
yes ok so here's why this is radically
enjoyable ill head Omar AOC where she
they've been using this crap against
everybody who disagrees with them for
months at this point if you disagree
with them it's because you want them to
receive death threats or you want them
to god forbid be killed or something
terrible like that it can't just be you
think they're idiots who say stupid and
terrible things all the time that they
all virtually all of those members have
been openly associated with vicious
anti-semites that their proposal ideas
are about as relevant as an ejector seat
on a helicopter
it can't be that it has to be that you
hate them because they are women of
color and because you want them to
receive death threats and now AOC is
taking that same exact charge and she's
leveling it at the speaker of her house
contingent it is fantastic and it
demonstrates how empty and stupid this
charge was in the first place
does anybody with a shred of rationality
actually believe that Nancy Pelosi wants
a OSI to receive death threats because a
OSI is a powerful woman of color does
anyone really believe that and if you do
believe that how gullible and dumb are
you if you really believe that Nancy
Pelosi is now the emissary of the old
white establishment because she's an old
white lady if you really believe that
that's what she is that's what she
represents man you guys that this is
crazy towns and it is wonderful it is
well-deserved everybody on the Left you
bought this ticket you take this ride
now so pick sides get on board which one
is it is it this via Romney iran-iraq
war from they get from the 80s which one
which side you on you got Tomatoes you
got sent I'm here okay which but which
one you want because you're gonna have
to pick either Nancy Pelosi the old
white lady who is apparently cracking
down on women of color or AOC the brash
newcomer who is labeling one of the most
impactful lawmakers in the last 50 years
a vicious racist for disagreeing with
her dumb policies and bad
is love it love it what what's amazing
about this even more than just the the
inherent wonder of the of the battle
between ANSI and Pelosi and AAS he's
playing the same game that Kamala Harris
plays about Joe Biden shoes s if she
thinks Pelosi is a racist and says no no
absolutely not absolutely not well then
how do you square that with she's
criticizing women of color because it's
I'm just pointing out a pattern Ayanna
Presley by the way said quote in my
districts we have 18 shooting since July
3rd I'm heading into oversight and a
child trauma hearing I've been
advocating for I'm not giving this any
more oxygen Ayanna Presley because I've
said is the Ringo Starr of this this
Beatles of stupidity in the House
Democratic caucus she is apparently the
least stupid of these folks because she
says I'm not jumping into this thing but
aoc is gonna jump into it this has some
actual impact beyond just the
congressional delegation for the
Democrats namely Democratic candidates
all over the country have no idea how
they are supposed to campaign they have
no clue how they are supposed to
campaign
take for example Democrat Amy McGrath so
Amy McGrath is the brand-new Senate
candidate facing down cocaine Mitch and
she's gonna take on Mitch McConnell in
Kentucky and she's hoping she can
convince Kentuckians who voted for Trump
and his pledge to drain the swamp that
Republican Mitch McConnell is the
biggest swamp dweller in Washington is
according to The Courier Journal in
Kentucky she said I fully recognize how
difficult this race will be and the
history behind folks have gone up
against Senator McConnell and then she
said that if President Trump has good
ideas then she will back those good
ideas she said a lot of Kentuckians
voted for Donald Trump because he wasn't
part of that political establishment on
either side for me I'm a Democrat my
husband's Republican I was an
independent for 12 years it's always
been about my country and in the middle
of this interview that she was doing she
made a very interesting statement about
justice Cavanaugh I'll explain in just
one second what exactly she said first
let me talk about personal security so
unlike some folks who may claim that
they receive serious security threats
every moment of every day I actually do
have security an enormous amount of the
time because we do get an enormous
number of threats and one of the reasons
that I have ring at my house is because
I want to make sure that my home is safe
at all times
you should have ring two rings mission
is to make neighborhood safer you might
already know about their smart video
doorbells and cameras to protect
millions of people everywhere ring helps
you stay connected to your home anywhere
in the world so if there's a package
delivery a surprise visitor you will get
an alert you'll be able to see see here
speak to them all from your phone you
know whenever I'm out of town on travel
and somebody rings the doorbell very
often you want to know who that is
because sometimes it's some creeper
who's ringing in the doorbell to make
sure that you're not home before they
invade your home and do something well
now when you're out of town you can
still pick it up from your phone you can
call the police it's pretty fantastic as
a subscriber you have a special offer on
a ring welcome kit available right now
at ring comm slash Ben the kit includes
video doorbell and a and a chime a pro
which is just what you need to start
building that ring of security around
your home today go-to ring comm slash
Ben that is ring that calm slash been
abusing ring for years you should too
ring calm slash Ben go check them out
right now okay so as I say this
Democratic Senate candidate is trying to
read the tea leaves in Kentucky which is
a state that Donald Trump won by 30
points and she's trying to figure out
how do I run can I run as a as a
moderate and maybe win or do I have to
please the aoc wing of the base and this
creates an enormous amount of confusion
so Amy McGrath who is this candidate
running against Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell she was asked about
justice Cavanaugh she said it's a good
question I didn't listen to all of the
hearings I don't think there was
anything and I'm not a lawyer or a
senator on the Judiciary Committee so I
don't know the criteria and I was very
concerned about justice about judge
Cavanaugh when I felt like there were
far-right stances that he had however
there was nothing in his record that I
think would disqualify him in any way
when the fact is when you have a
president in the Senate this is our
system and so I don't think there was
anything that would have disqualified
him in my mind and then she was asked by
the courier-journal to the Democrats
treat him unfairly with the accusations
that were against him waiting until the
last minute if some have said to trying
to lay the hearings McGrath said the
Supreme Court nominees are a lifetime
appointment I don't fault anyone for
bringing up things that could give folks
pause about the character of someone
getting a lifetime appointment and then
she said that she thought that Christine
Blasi Ford's accusations against justice
Cavanaugh were credible she said I think
it's credible but given the amount of
time that elapsed in between and from a
judicial standpoint I don't think it
would really disqualify him and she said
yeah I think I probably would have voted
for Brett Kavanaugh which is the correct
answer in Kentucky and Kentucky
if you're democrat that is the correct
answer because if you looked at the
polls you know it was wildly unpopular
among Americans the attempt by Democrats
to deprive Cavanaugh of due process
based on an evidence less allegation by
one person brought at the last minute
by Democratic partisans hey but Amy
McGrath is now caught up in this
Maelstrom inside the Democratic Party of
are you with a OC or you with Nancy
Pelosi are you with the progressive wing
or are you with the people who actually
want to win so and then Amy McGrath did
what is called the rare political double
flip-flop as comfortably smug put it on
Twitter I mean the Russian judges gave
it a ten Amy McGrath tweeted out I was
asked earlier today about judge Brett
Kavanaugh and I answered based upon his
qualifications to be on the Supreme
Court but upon further reflection and
further understanding of his record I
would have voted no so she said yeah I
would have voted for him and then she
says no I wouldn't have voted for him
and then she continues and tweets out I
know I disappointed many today with my
initial answer on how I would have voted
on Brett Kavanaugh I will make mistakes
and always own up to them the priority
is defeating Mitch McConnell now she
originally before that interview in The
Courier Journal said she wouldn't have
ohed it for Cavanaugh so she said no I
won't vote for him yes I will vote for
him no I won't vote for him and this is
all coming because Democrats don't know
how to read their own party base at this
point one of the things that's been
happening is that the political parties
in the United States and Donald Trump is
excellent proof of this the political
parties in the United States no longer
know how to read their own base they
don't know how to read the people they
represent because here's here's the
truth about American politics there are
those of us who spend our days and
nights thinking about the sort of stuff
and we try to create intellectual
frameworks for how people are going to
vote we try to create these sort of
philosophies that we believe people
should vote based upon and parties try
to do the same thing but parties do it
in a dumb way they don't try to create
kind of general philosophies that they
think people are aspiring to they
instead try to create party platforms
that are basically an agglomeration of
issues that they think are popular
enough with a particular group of people
that they can win a majority this is
what Democrats are trying to do right
now by pandering to every group Under
the Sun it's what Republicans have done
in the past by putting together this
weird amalgamation of everything from
some tariffs and no tariffs to we're
kind of socially liberal we're kind of
socially conservative been very unclear
what the overall philosophy actually has
been now the truth is that voters are
neither of these things voters number
one generally don't vote based on an
overarching philosophy and number two
don't vote based on an agglomeration of
policy positions voters based on voters
vote based on personality and comfort
level in general sort of feeling about
the country and the narrative
surrounding the country and that's why
everything has become a culture war in
politics but the pilot the parties have
been unable to capture the nature of
those cultures that's why Donald Trump
has continued to be effective the reason
Trump is effective is because he's a
cultural warrior by the way this is also
why Obama was effective in 2008 he ran
effectively as a culture warrior against
a divisive nosov courses that he then
reversed himself and proved to be an
extraordinarily divisive president
Donald Trump looked at the divisions in
the country and he said these divisions
are very real and one side is being
ignored and I'm going to tell those
folks that they are being ignored and
they're being left behind that was
Trump's pitch that was not a political
pitch it was not a philosophical pitch
it was an emotional pitch and it was
properly he was properly aimed and
directed at the right number of voters
but the parties are not able to do that
because the parties of course have
candidates all over the country who have
local constituencies and so you ends up
with this weird attempt to create
national parties from local
constituencies that differ widely Amy
McGrath's state he's not going to look
anything like a OCS district and yet
Amy McGrath requires the support of
people like a OC in order to go forward
and this creates an unbridgeable divide
you're seeing this play out in the
Democratic primaries right now hey who
exactly is representative of the
Democratic base is it Joe Biden who
represents a plurality of Democrats or
is it Connell Harris who represents a
smaller minority of Democrats but a more
passionate minority of Democrats perhaps
all of this leads to tremendous
confusion inside the party system and
it's why the party system is starting to
break down and that's gonna be bad
particularly for the parties that are
unable to hold together any semblance of
unity right now that looks a lot more
like the Democrats and it does like the
Republicans it's also why it would
really behoove president Trump to stop
being so divisive inside his own caucus
by saying dumb things what I mean by
that is the president Trump today
started tweeting out some things again
it is it is
to me all Donald Trump has to do is shut
up inhuman reelection that is literally
all he has to do all he has to do is
shut up and point and pointed the
Democrats and instead he's out there
tweeting weird crap and giving people a
level of disquiet with his presidency
that is unwarranted by his record today
he got on Twitter and he just started
tweeting out random nonsense I mean I
don't know if he's just bored today or
what but he started tweeting out here's
what the president tweeted he tweeted
out a big subject today at the White
House social media summit will be the
tremendous dishonesty bias
discrimination and suppression practiced
by certain companies we will not let
them get away with it much longer the
fake news media will also be there but
for a limited period the fake news is
not as important or as powerful as
social media is so far fine they've lost
tremendous credibility since that day in
November 2016 then I came down the
escalator with the person who has to
become your future first lady well that
was actually like 2015 anyway he says
when I will ultimately leave office in
six years or maybe 10 or 14 just kidding
the it will quickly go out of business
for lack of credibility or approval from
the public that's why they will all be
endorsing me at some point one way or
the other could you imagine having
sleepy Joe Biden or Alfred Newman
I assume that's people who to judge or a
very nervous and skinny version of
Pocahontas 1000 / 24th that's not how
fractions work as your president rather
than what you have now so great looking
and smart a true stable genius capital s
capital G sorry to say that even social
media would be driven out of business
along with and finally the fake news
media what in the actual f is that what
in the actual world in listen ok I get
there people who are clapping and
cheering yeah ok here is the problem the
economy is really good right now
it continues to be really good right now
the economy continues to be great for
job creation the Dow Jones Industrial
Average just hit 27 thousand for the
first time in history ok so what would
it what are we doing here why why when
chaos is breaking out on the other side
let them have their firefight why are
you doing this why it's so funny Trump
put out a tweet
with an ad created by somebody else
about his leadership in his presidency
and the ad is well produced if the
president was george w bush because what
the ad was was this very soothing music
talking about President Trump has stood
strong and unwavering in the storm
President Trump is a man who has deep
abiding character and who sticks with
his principles and he calls all of this
just to start it will take a typical
presidential candidate there's only one
problem everybody knows that ain't Trump
meaning that there's a group of people
who think that that is Trump but those
people basically work for him everybody
else understands that the dudes of
volatile character that comes along with
a lot of benefits and a lot of drawbacks
and really if you would just stop and
everything would be okay why does
everyone seek to stitute draw defeat
from the jaws of victory how I've been
saying for years about the Democrats all
they had to do was not be crazy and they
literally could not do it it was
impossible for them and then you got
Trump and he decides he wants to do the
same thing I'm so supremely confused
about why he would do that it is it is
beyond me okay now in just a second let
me get to the latest scandal that is is
now surrounding the Trump administration
really isn't about the Trump
administration at all it's really about
the criminal justice system in the
United States there's confusing
confusion surrounding the Jeffrey
Epstein scandal
Alex Acosta Trump Secretary of Labor is
under fire we'll talk about that in one
second first hiring used to be rough
not anymore when someone makes the
slightest most minor insignificant
mistake here on the bench Shapiro show
except for me we know how easily we can
replace them
thanks to zip recruiter everybody here
is unknown as zip recruiter is the
greatest threat to their job but also it
makes your business better
zip recruit comm slash daily wear by the
way you don't have to fire anybody just
to use zip ricoeur maybe you want to
hire some new people because your
business is growing the way we are here
at Daily wire that's why we use zip
recruit or not just to replace that
applause to work for us zip recruiter
sends your job posting to over 100 of
the web's leading job boards but they
don't stop there as applications come in
zip recruiter analyzes each one
spotlights the top candidates so you
never miss a great match zipper cooter
is so effective that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter can
equality candidate through the site
within the very first day right now my
listeners can try out zip recruiter for
free at this exclusive web address zip
recruiter com daily wire that's zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire you help
us out
use our advertisers by the way but
you'll be helping yourself out a lot
more if you're looking to hire zip
recruiters comm slash Daily wire zip
recruiter is the smartest way to hire go
check them out right now
zip recruiter comm slash daily wear okay
and just a second we'll get to the
latest on the Jeffrey Epstein scandal
plus the President of the United States
preparing later today to announce some
sort of executive action on the census
will explain whether this is a good idea
or whether this is a bad idea whether
it's a constitutional crisis everybody
likes that phrase I'll get to that in
just a few minutes first great news gang
if you've ever wondered what it would be
like to sit in on an episode of our
backstage live show and why wouldn't you
wonder that I mean doesn't everyone or
the chance to ask us a question in
person your time has come we are taking
the show on the road August 21st said
the terrorist theater in Long Beach
California that is correct
hi daily where God can Jeremy boring
Andrew Klavan the execrable Michael
moles and even more important than
Noel's The Daily wire merchandise table
will be there live the merchandise table
will be dead all the rest of us will be
alive unfortunately in the case of
Knowles tickets are on sale right now at
daily wire.com slash backstage there's
still a few VIP ticket packages
available those include premium seating
photos and meet and greets of each of us
a gift from me I mean I'm out shopping
for it right now just for you and more
so head on over to daily wire.com slash
backstage get your tickets we will see
you there you never know it might be a
locket I'll lock it with a picture I
don't know what it's gonna be yet guys
head on over to daily wire.com slash of
backstage and get those tickets also
give us your subscriptions like really
it helps us it protects us from the
vicissitudes of the nasty left which
tries to deprive us of our advertisers
and tries to g-platform us go over to
daily wire come right now and subscribe
$9.99 a month 99 bucks eater gets you
this the greatest in all beverage
vessels whoo whoo check that out right
there you got that for 19 bucks a year
we are the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
you
all righty so the big story of yesterday
aside from the AOC Nancy Pelosi smash-up
which was just wonderful aside from that
it was Alex Acosta as the Secretary of
Labor defending himself from allegations
that he cut a sweetheart deal with
ledged pedophile Jeffrey Epstein who's
apparently engaged in high-level sex
trafficking of minors and there are all
sorts of questions that are still out
there about Jeffrey Epstein like how did
this guy make so much money a he
apparently there's no record of him
being with this wonderful investment
specialist so how did he make his
billions of dollars buying private
islands and all of us where did this
money come from how did he get away with
this for so long why was it that Cyrus
Vance one of the GA over in Manhattan
why did he try to keep Epstein from
being registered as a top-level sex
offender once Epstein moved full-time to
New York why exactly was he not required
to check in with the NYPD every 90 days
as he would be as a as a high-level sex
offender he never checked in at all over
an 8-year span how was he able to get
away with that this stuff goes beyond
Alex Acosta Jim Garrity over at National
Review has a good rundown on some of
these questions he says how did Jeffrey
Epstein make that fortune one claim a
massive Ponzi scheme but wouldn't that
bring the securities folks down on his
head could Epstein really have been
connected to some sort of intelligence
service there were reports yesterday
that may be the reason Epstein was left
alone is because he was connected with
the intelligence services in doing work
for them when asked about this Alex
Acosta offered a weird vague
contradictory meandering answer if
Epstein was working for some sort of spy
agency which would what was the am
collecting blackmail and prominent
figures who's being blackmailed there's
an allegation that maybe the way he made
his money is from blackmail maybe the
way that he made his money is he was
trafficking all these underage women and
underage girls as young as 14 13 years
old having them in compromising
positions with older men who were very
powerful than blackmailing those guys
for cash after Epstein as I say was
handed that level 3 sex offender status
he was required to check in with the
NYPD they never required him to why did
the Manhattan district attorney try to
keep Epstein from being registered as a
top-level sex offender I mean this is
this is ridiculous apparently a seasoned
sex crimes prosecutor from Vance's
office argued forcefully in court that
should not be registered that way in New
York as a sex offender
in New York the judge said I have to
tell you this I'm a little overwhelmed
I've never seen a prosecutor's office do
anything like this how is it that his
private island off st. Thomas got the
nickname pedophile island and how did
that not exactly get the authorities
snooping around Bill Clinton's public
statements about his interactions with
Epstein those are wildly inaccurate they
are contradicted by contemporary igneous
media accounts as well as FAA flight
logs also apparently Trump at what
President Trump you know it was quoted
in a recent Vanity Fair article there
was an article about Trump and David
pecker of National Enquirer
in which Trump apparently told pecker
that the pictures of Clinton that
Epstein had from his Island were worse
now is it did Clinton visit the island
unclear does Epstein have that sort of
material why did Alex Acosta cut him
such a sweetheart deal they're
contradictory they're sort of
contradictory accounts as to how
sweetheart the deal was can white Pope
had on Twitter he says that this deal is
the sweetest deal he's ever seen he has
an article over at the Atlantic saying
quote the the Jeffrey Epstein case is
like nothing I've ever seen before say
great wealth insulates people from
consequences but not always absolutely
or forever he talks about the facts that
this deal basically prevented further
prosecution in the area what in the hell
was going on and then on the other hand
you have a woman named Kimberly Melman
Orosco writing for USA Today who is a an
expert witness on sex trafficking and
she says I've seen deals like this
before so how out of the ordinary is all
of this all of this is is deeply
troubling and upsetting of course and
the fact that and the fact that you know
all the facts are gonna come out means
there will be as I have been saying for
days a lot more shoes to drop okay
meanwhile the other big news of the day
is that President Trump is about to take
executive action on a census citizenship
question that is supposed to happen and
like two o'clock today Pacific time five
o'clock p.m. Eastern and according to
Margaret talev
reporting for Bloomberg President Trump
will announce executive action on the
2020 US census on Thursday pursuing his
fight to include a citizenship question
in the decennial population count
despite being rebuffed by the supreme
court the executive action is expected
to be an
at a news conference according to three
people familiar with Trump's plan they
declined to detail the action they
indicated it may not be an executive
order it may instead be the fire vaguer
executive action it's an executive order
has at least some precedent in American
law typically executive orders are
issued in order to carry out a
constitutionally authorized duty an
executive action it's unclear what
exactly that constitutes and it has a
far murkier status in American
constitutional law cuz it's kind of made
up is the truth Trump announced that he
would be previewing that he announced
the news conference in a tweet talking
about the social media summit he said at
the conclusion of the social media
summit we will go to the beautiful Rose
Garden for a news conference on a census
and citizenship so there are a couple of
theories about exactly what Trump is
going to do later this afternoon
obviously the Supreme Court has
denounced the census questions saying
that it was pretextual the rationale
provided by the Trump administration was
an absurd decision we talked about it on
the show the idea the Supreme Court is
now going to look at the relevant and
correct provided rationales for asking
something as simple as are you a citizen
on these census and then they're gonna
say the real reason you're doing this is
cuz you're racist and so we're not going
to allow you to do it that is far beyond
the boundaries of what the judiciary
should be allowed to do or is allowed to
do under their constitutionally
delegated status
this leaves Trump with a couple of
possible options one of those options is
more controversial and one of those
options is less controversial the option
that is less controversial the option
that is less controversial is the option
that basically president Trump invokes a
specific provision of the Constitution
and says I have a constitutional duty to
ask this question
Josh hammer editor-at-large over here at
Daily wire he points out that there is a
provision of the Constitution in the
Fourteenth Amendment section 2 text that
says this when the right to vote is
denied to any of the male inhabitants of
such state being 21 years of age and
citizens of the United States or in any
way abridged except for participation in
rebellion or other crime the basis of
representation therein shall be reduced
in the proportion which the number of
such male citizens shall bear to the
whole number of male citizens 21 years
of age in such state so what does that
mean the 14th amendment basically says
that if a state of bridges the right to
vote was written to stop
southern states from stopping black
people from voting that the federal
government could then abridge the the
voting power of that state congressional
reapportionment would take place wherein
there would be a to variable formula and
each variable will require citizenship
data so in other words in order to make
possible the implementation of this
Clause you do have to have an accurate
count of the number of people in the
country legally in a particular district
and that that would be the case that the
the White House that the executive
branch is mandated to do this by the
Fourteenth Amendment section 2 that
seems fairly clear-cut actually so that
is the less controversial way of doing
it there's a solid legal rationale it
seems fairly unchallengeable what is the
Supreme Court gonna say we will not
allow you to ask a question that you are
constitutionally mandated to ask so that
you can actually fulfill the obligations
of amendment 14 and that is the less
controversial way of doing it the more
controversial way of doing it as Trump
just says screw you to the Supreme Court
and goes ahead and puts a censorship
question on there doesn't offer any
rationale and says listen we have the
power under the census Act if Congress
wants to deprive us of that power it can
do so at any time but we are not bound
by extraordinary judicial decisions now
in the one hand I like the first move
because it is indeed less controversial
legally and it's a pretty obvious out on
the other hand I have long been an
advocate of the notion of departmental
ISM depart mentalism is the basic idea
that the Supreme Court does not get to
tell all of the other branches that its
interpretation of the Constitution is
paramount there's a difference in other
words between judicial review and
judicial supremacy so judicial review is
the idea that the Supreme Court and the
judiciary of the United States has the
ability to decide whether it will apply
a law that is in conflict with the
Constitution of the United States but
that is not traditional supremacy
meaning that the supreme courts
interpretation of the Constitution
itself is not paramount they are not
Kings they are not caddies sitting under
trees deciding how the Constitution is
to be applied to everyone but the
Supreme Court does not get to tell every
other branch how to do its business
especially because they're unelected how
would that work in practice well it'd
work like this let's say that the let's
say that there was a piece of
legislation
that the Supreme Court found to be
unconstitutional well then the judiciary
of the United States would simply refuse
to apply that that law at all right it
would become inoperative in the judicial
system and what would happen if the
other branches decided that let's say
the executive branch wanted to go ahead
with something like the census question
well then it falls to Congress doesn't
it which is where it should be that's
where it should be if Congress wants to
take back power from the presidency they
can do that at any time by revising the
census Act that is all they have to do
this is a political question the Marbury
vs. Madison decision which has been
there's a solid case we made it has been
misread for years to suggest judicial
supremacy rather than judicial review
the Marbury vs. Madison decision is a
very untenable decision legally that is
not just my opinion that's the opinion
of folks like Alexander Bickel former
Yale law professor who wrote a very
famous book called the least dangerous
branch it's the opinion of University of
Minnesota law professor Michael Stokes
Paulson the the judge learned at hand
when the most famous jurists of the of
the 20th century made the same point
Marbury vs. Madison is a very very weak
decision and the idea that the the
judiciary is paramount and has the sole
authority to decide the role of the
Constitution in American life is
obviously not supported by either law or
theory when you read the Federalist
Papers even folks who believe that
Federalist 78 by Alexander Hamilton
backs the notion of judicial supremacy
ignore the part where Hamilton
specifically says if the judiciary
starts to use will instead of power it
would obviate the need for a separate
branch called the judiciary they would
then become a dictatorship so judicial
review depart mentalism in which
basically each department gets to decide
which how the Constitution is to be
interpreted and then there's interplay
between the various branches of
government that seems more like the
checks and balances the founders had in
mind then the artificially created power
of judicial supremacy which really
didn't come into full fledge until like
the Dred Scott decision the worst
decision in the history of the United
States so we'll talk I'm sure a little
bit more about this a little bit later
when we find out exactly what President
Trump is doing here okay time for some
things I like and then some things that
I hate so speaking of checks and
balances the basis for checks and
balances in American legal theory comes
largely courtesy of
to Montesquieu you've all heard
Montesquieu's name if you've had any
level of familiarity with founding era
ideology Montesquieu was the philosopher
who was cited most often in founding era
papers in founding era documents
Montesquieu of course a French
philosopher he wrote a book called the
spirit of the laws 7 an 800-page book
there's a very good Cambridge edition
that cleans it up just a little bit or
translates it at least in the clearest
possible way and Montesquieu's two basic
contributions to American philosophy are
the idea of political Liberty meaning
that government is there to provide a
sort of safe backdrop for YouTube for
you to exercise your Liberty but Liberty
is not you get to do whatever you want
Liberty has to be circumscribed by your
ability to harm somebody else and also
the idea of checks and balances so
checks and balances come directly from
Montesquieu Montesquieu talk
specifically about the need for power to
balance power and ambition to balance
ambition half of the Federalist Papers
is straight Montesquieu so this is it's
worth the read it is not an easy read
there's a lot of history it's sort of
the first comparative political work so
he tries to compare the various legal
systems of everything from China to
India to France to Britain and tries to
figure out what is the best system he
talks about what he termed sort of the
tripartite distinction and governments
between despotism monarchy and
republicanism he talks about sort of the
motivating factors behind each she says
the monarchy is driven by a sense of
honor the despotism is driven by power
and that republicanism
is driven by a sense of virtue and that
there's a lot there it's world it's well
worth the read I'm using it heavily I'm
writing another book right now all about
rights and duties and Montesquieu comes
into play so give that a read if you're
interested in founding era philosophy
okay time for some things that I hate
okay so thing that I hate number one one
of the things that you are starting to
see in American life is the decline of
religion but religion itself is not the
cloning it is just being supplanted by
either a sort of atavistic narcissistic
weird self focus or or it's being
supplanted with political religion and
those are those are the two substitutes
there's the political religion of
leftism which has its own system of
virtue and penalties it has its own
system of sin sins that can never be
expiated by the way if you ever commit a
sin under the system of leftism it can
never be wiped away unless you do full
penance and even then we will still hold
the sin over your head if you if you
become politically unavailable or you do
something that crosses the party line
then you will be the sin will be brought
back up and used against you political
religion has become the way that we do
our politics right now which is why you
see such near religious feeling about
politics you're starting to see people
who don't actually have church
communities and don't talk with their
friends and don't talk with their
neighbors and they're supplanting this
with a sense of religious virtue when it
comes to and undoubted religious virtue
when it comes to their own politics so
if you disagree with prevailing views
about how climate change should be dealt
with namely with vast transnational
regulation if you oppose that then you
are a denier here I mean this is
religious type language you're you're
then it's and I or even if you accept
that climate change is happening just
like the IPCC says it is if you disagree
with the left's prevailing wisdom about
income inequality then you have sinned
and you are in all likelihood a
plutocrat and a white supremacist if you
are somebody who believes that the chief
method of escaping poverty in the United
States is not railing against phantom
institutional racism and when I say
phantom I don't mean that racism doesn't
exist in American society it very
clearly does I am saying that
institutional racism meaning laws on the
books things you can point out where you
say this institution is acting in this
racist manner specifically designed to
harm this class of people used to plant
that for if you say that is less
effective as a strategy it is first of
all not true and second of all it is
less effective as a strategy
and then encouraging people to make
proper individual decisions if you say
that you've you've violated the left
sense of political sin so there there is
this political religion out there and
leftism feels it in abundance which is
why you see from the left the sort of
Megan Rapinoe attitude which is I'm not
going to talk to anybody who disagrees
with me they are sinners and they must
be cast into the hell in flames and then
there is actual paganism and there is a
return listen people have religious
instincts the religious instinct is
twofold one to put an organized
principle on all of life to look at the
patterns around us in the world and try
to discern those patterns and try to
figure out what exactly is going on
around us this is what the human brain
does and that leads in some cases to the
idea of a unifying creator who created a
natural plan this is how you gets the
idea of natural law you can also get to
the idea that there is some phantom hand
of economics that stands behind
everything so that that instinctively
that is a religious instinct to try and
put an order on everything it also
happens to lead to beliefs about science
so it's a good instinct but it has to be
channeled in the proper direction and
then there is the other aspect of
religious thought which is the need for
belief in something beyond that which we
can see they need to believe something
because we here's the problem you have
that religious instinct to put a pattern
on everything but there are a lot of
things that don't fit the pattern so
where exactly do you put those things
well in the religious kind of
traditionally judeo-christian worldview
you say listen God has a plan I have a
plan my plan is not God's plan God's
plan is beyond me but then there's still
the need for mysticism for people who
don't believe in the judeo-christian
system or anumana theistic system at all
and so they find that need for a
mystical outreach to something beyond
them something beyond their own flesh
and bones and they find this in some of
the weirdest places lately they've been
seeking it in everything from kind of
self-help gurus to healing crystals
there's an article in the LA Times today
called how Millennials replace religion
with astrology and crystals this makes
sense by the way because again the
religious instinct in some ways that
first religious instinct to put order on
pass it's very similar to the scientific
instinct and so science and religion
don't have to be in conflict in fact I
make the case in my book the right side
of history that judeo-christian religion
combined with Greek teleology actually
led to the rise of Western science and
that
in fact you could combine Greek
teleology with other monotheistic
religions and probably create science
that would be just as good if you could
maintain that balance but when you get
away from the idea of a God who stands
behind an ordered universe then you
throw away science to you you leave the
the once you get to the the universe is
chaotic and you just sort of worship at
the altar of the chaos you get to back
to astrology and crystals so here's what
the LA Times says quote I love myself I
am beautiful it was a nun seasonably
chilly night for June in Los Angeles
about three dozen people mostly women in
their 20s and 30s we're spending their
Friday evening lying on yoga mats on the
back patio of a shop a few blocks from
Hollywood Forever Cemetery and the
Paramount Pictures lot attendees had
been invited to bring whatever they
needed to make the space cozy blankets
pillows crystals I am powerful Anna
Lilla was leading them in affirmations
closing out a 98 90-minute breath work
session celebrating the summer solstice
I am a bright light I am ready to be
seen most days lilia works with
individual clients in the evenings she
teaches classes or puts on events such
as the Solstice gathering she first got
into breathwork four years ago and
started taking classes to become a
teacher six months later if you've never
done it before it's a mix of breathing
exercises and guided meditations meant
to relax you and help connect with your
inner thoughts a cross between the last
10 minutes of the yoga class and a
therapy session takes in place entirely
in your head she's one of a growing
number of young people largely
millenials though the trend extends to
younger genic sir's now cresting 40 and
down to Gen Z the oldest of whom are
freshly-minted college grads who have
turned away from traditional organized
religion and are embracing more
spiritual beliefs and practices like
Tarot like Terra Tarot astrology
astrology meditation energy healing and
crystals now the only times a
journalistic outlet you would think that
they would say embracing crap like Tarot
astrology energy healing and crystals
meditation is an actual what there's
some scientific proof that meditation
helps relax you but energy healing
crystals Tarot astrology all this
garbage and know they but don't
particularly care if you think it's
whoo-whoo or weird most Millennials
claim not to take any of it too
seriously themselves they dabble they
find what they like they take what works
for them and leave the rest
voguing consternation from buttoned-up
outsiders is far from a drawback it's a
fringe benefit the cause behind the
spirit
shift is a combination of factors in
more than a dozen interviews for this
story with people ranging in age from 18
to their early 40s a common theme
emerged they were raised with one set of
religious beliefs Catholic Jewish
Buddhist but as they became adults they
felt that faith didn't completely
represent who they were or what they
believed I'll tell you what the common
thread there is probably they grew up in
not particularly religious households
Catholic Jewish Buddhist for sure Jewish
I'll speak to Jewish the vast majority
people who are doing this did not grow
up in religious Jewish household
household the Jews who are doing this
they grew up in reformed Jewish
household maybe conservative Jewish
households likely reconstructionist
Jewish households in other words
households that didn't actually explain
and what Judaism was what its standards
were what the spirituality of Judaism is
it had watered-down religion to the
point where it was basically a soft form
of spirituality anyway and then they
just went and searched for another soft
form of spirituality that didn't come
along with the judgmentalism and that
that is really what people are going for
and you're seeing this is spanning the
oceans as well there's a report today
from the UK that says that less than 1%
of young people identify as Church of
England in the UK which was the official
Church of England only 1% of people aged
18 to 24 identify as Church of England
according to the British total social
attitudes survey for 2018 even among
over 75 the most religious age group
only one and three people describe
themselves as Church of England 52% of
the public now say they do not belong to
any religion it was 31% in 1983 when the
when the survey began tracking religious
belief the number of people identifying
as Christian has now fallen from 66
percent to 38 percent in Britain now
there are a lot of people who say who
cares what's the big deal the reason
that it's a big deal
is because again there is a human
instinct for religious belief and it is
going to be filled by something whether
there's a religious following of a
political figure which is what you are
increasingly seeing whether it is
religious following of a political ideal
the substitution of environment of the
environment for God for example the
substitution of particular ideas of
equality for ideas from the ordered
universe and that's bad ones politics
become so there was a point in human
history when religion was politics and
when when rulership was was done via
theocracy and when most of the wars that
we had were in turn a seemed religious
when it was Protestant versus Catholic
and Catholic versus Muslim and and
Muslim and Catholic versus Jew and those
very very bad can religious warfare is
the worst kind of warfare because there
is literally no way to have a
conversation you cannot have a
conversation with somebody when your
belief is that they are going directly
to hell and you're going directly to
heaven and that is the subject of the
conversation you can't have
conversations that way
religious religious conflict is
religious warfare when politics falls
back into the realm of religion
undoubted religious belief systems
you're gonna end up with exactly that
same sort of conflict again so we moved
away from religious conflict in toward
political conflict and political
conflicts was us having secular
arguments with one another about right
and wrong a lot of those arguments were
rooted in the judeo-christian value
system in fact nearly all of them were
but those arguments taking place in that
common framework of a value system
rather than a specific doctrinal belief
system that led to the rise of smaller
republicanism and elections and the idea
that sure we can agree to disagree and
now what we are seeing is as that
religious instinct wanes as people no
longer fulfill that religious instinct
by going to church or by going to
synagogue instead they're fulfilling it
with politics itself so we took politics
and we removed religion from it except
for sort of the over lasting morality of
religion and now politics is becoming
religion it's it's own religion now and
so you're going to return to the
religious warfare of the past where your
religious belief is defined by your
politics itself and I don't mean like
you're a member of a church that's
political I mean that the politics
itself is the religion and everyone who
disagrees with you is cast into eternal
Hellfire that is where we read for a
small our republic it is it is very bad
for a democracy to turn politics into
religion incredibly incredibly dangerous
because there is nothing to bind us
anymore and that's the other fact hey as
a religion declines religion is one of
those areas where people find
commonality in diversity you can have a
diverse group of people if they are all
oriented toward the same thing so Robert
Putnam sociologist over at Harvard
University he talked about the fact that
ethnic diversity is not necessarily
strengthening to a community in fact he
uses the the sort of throwaway line but
it's not really throwaway sociology he
uses
the survey one the database line that as
ethnic diversity increases in a
community the only two things that
increase our protest marches and
television watching but he says that
what can unify a community is a central
sense of identity a sense that we are
all oriented in the same direction that
we are all praying to the same God
for example the we're all going to the
same church today versus diversity is
enriching and is good when you share a
set of common values so in a church in
the Army so what is that set of common
values going to be we've seen a bunch of
attempts to create a set of common
values so nationalism has been posited
as a possible solution to this a
nationalistic ideal but the problem is
that nationalism isn't necessarily good
or evil there can be German nationalism
circa 1930 there can be American
nationalism circa nineteen forty one
makes a very different nationalism and
one is good and one is really really not
it depends on the nature of the
nationalism so can that fill the gap
only if it turns out that the
nationalism itself is a vessel that is
filled with a philosophy of philosophy
rooted in exactly the judeo-christian
value systems that are now being thrown
away so I'm not sure empty nationalism
does the trick how about the
constitutional values now I've said that
you can believe constitutional values
you can believe the philosophies of the
founding without being a religious human
being in fact many of the founders were
tended toward II ISM you can do that but
they were running on the fumes of the
judeo-christian value system the vast
majority of our founders were in fact
practicing Christians they certainly did
not disdain religion in the same way
that our politicians do now and as much
of our population does as we throw away
the fundamental basis for the philosophy
that created the west can that
philosophy itself last in an era of
secularism I'm not sure that it can I
mean this is what my book the right side
of history is all about so the and then
finally there's a third factor as you
throw away religion as I mentioned
earlier as you throw away the idea of an
ordered universe where the human mind is
capable of understanding things around
it these are religious principles but
these are principles that you cannot
suss out you cannot rationality these
things you cannot you cannot use your
rationality to get to these fundamental
principles you have to just assume them
once you get rid of those fundamental
principles you end up back in this
bizarre paganistic world where
everything is too
fine by you yourself the only perception
that matters is your subjective
perception and so if you believe in
healing crystals then healing crystals
are true if you believe in energy
healing then energy healing is true it
doesn't matter science which is an
objective standard which puts again a
framework of logic on the universe that
no longer matters because we've thrown
away the framework of logic why should
the universe operate by laws or rules
what suggest that it does all that we're
playing with fire here
and we are we are in the middle of one
of the great experiments in human
history and that experiment is whether
you can take the moral and philosophic
of the richest most powerful most
progressive system in world history
throw away the basis and keep the rest
I am very doubtful that that is going to
be the case as we move forward in time
all righty we'll be back here a little
bit later today with two additional
hours of content and then we will be
back here tomorrow as well I'll see you
then I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright day Lee Weyer
2019 hey guys over on the mat wall
showed a federal Roark went and met with
some refugees and immigrants and he
proceeded to trash America America's
racist horrible country so on and so
forth what a great guy bet O'Rourke is
we'll talk about that today also AOC
speaking of great people
AOC basically implies that Nancy Pelosi
is racist which is kind of hilarious but
also disgusting and we'll talk about
that finally I want to discuss the very
common modern practice of filming
troubled people in the midst of mental
breakdowns so that we can laugh at them
online I think that maybe we should stop
doing that and we'll talk about the
latest example of that today
overall the Matt Walsh show